you had a recent trip to the middle east
and you talked a bunch about uh bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies regulation
infrastructure et cetera tell us a
little bit about the trip why did you go
and kind of what was the conversation
like with the middle eastern investors
well the largest pension our sovereign
funds in the world or in the middle east
and and i was i really wanted you know
this there's policies that comes out of
the region but then there's also the
opportunity to sit down and talk to the
leadership there about what their
intentions are
in uh specifically bitcoin mining i was
interested to see if there was a way to
invest together
um because
what they're contemplating in some of
these countries are sovereign um mining
operations
and so
what what is that going to look like and
so what i learned and this is because
you were talking about institutional
adoption so let me tell you what i think
is going to happen in the next 24 36
months
on on this very topic once a sovereign
fund decides it's going to invest in
bitcoin
it's going to want to mine it
sustainably and ethically because we've
got a lot of controversy started last
year i remember at bitcoin 2021
and the whole elon musk thing we've
talked about it a lot the conversation
around esg and and is mining bitcoin
going to be compliant with the esg
mandates specifically the larry
fincletter the largest asset manager on
earth blackrock and so
this is what they're this is what i'm
getting out of this conversation and the
way i think i'm going to invest because
i've always wanted to open up my own
mining operations and i'm going to
probably do it in this calendar year so
number one
is it approved by the community it's set
up in both politically and by the people
that live there what's the plan to give
back to that community so let's take a
nordic country
sweden or norway or something like that
where a lot of these adoptions are
occurring it's happening in west texas
too but the whole idea is that you go to
that town in west texas and you you have
an agreement with the mayor and the city
council like you're you're compliant
with them to start off with you're going
to give back to the grid whatever it's
going to be you're going to mine from
this
from the
the stack heat maybe you do hydroponics
whatever it is you get them on board
number two
can you
keep the
the award if when you get awarded a coin
can you keep it on the balance sheet so
i as an institution can buy your equity
i don't have to buy the coin i don't
have to go to my committee and say i'm
buying bitcoin anymore i just buy your
stock and now i own the coin as long as
you make the promise to me that you're
never going to sell it because now i
know what's being mined ethically i know
what's being mined with the community in
mind i know the political environment
there's on board i'm not breaching any
regulations and now i own the coin and i
get exposure to the price through the
equity
i tell you guys that's what's going to
happen this year you're going to see a
ton of capital go into these new
projects
some of them will use old chinese stacks
because they're all exiting the country
all that equipment and they're going to
be set up in jurisdictions just like the
way i described it with the equity being
the way the institution owns exposure to
bitcoin pricing and those are the deals
i'm going to invest in so when you think
about that um are there places in the
middle east that you think this will
happen or is it too hot there is the
political climate not ready for like how
do you think of the middle east fitting
into that because you mentioned the
nordic countries you mentioned places
like west texas is the middle east
potentially a place they got a lot of
oil and a lot of power production going
on there like how do they think about it
well they also have nuclear power there
too they have excessive electricity
available it's about the cooling you're
right about that there may be a way and
this is being explored by a couple of
ventures right now to build
the facilities way underground in the
underneath the sand like way down so the
cooling becomes far more efficient these
are really really large stacks we're
talking about big
you know close to billion dollar
facilities
i think in this
the way to start thinking about this and
i've come to the conclusion is
different jurisdictions
let's let's take if you're an investor
like me you've got to find jurisdictions
where
they're compliant with the local
regulator now the most advanced in my
mind right now
is canada canada was the first to allow
you to do an etf with bitcoin as the
underlying asset then they opened it up
for ethereum now they have multiple etfs
in that jurisdiction that people from
all around the world are investing in
compliant with the regulator
they just licensed the very first market
crypto exchange the very first in canada
so it got me thinking where else is this
going to happen what other jurisdictions
are going to open this up and licenses
are going to be granted eastern europe
nordic countries middle east regions so
i'm on an airplane all the time now i'm
going to meet with regulators saying
look this is what we did in canada
can we do this here
and when they say yes i'll invest there
too
i
i want to be
in the exchange business why because i'm
agnostic to price the more volatility
there is the better it is for me so if i
make 8 or 10 or 12 basis points every
time you're trading
i'm in a great place it's the picks and
shovels of the the future of bitcoin and
digital currencies and payment systems i
want to be part of the exchange all
right before we talk about the exchange
required one last question about the uh
the mining
if i tweeted and said kevin o'leary is
considering investing in an underground
desert
bitcoin mining facility would that be
like an accurate statement
not yet not yet not yet because the
technology has not been proven got it
it's it's it's being
conceptualized but the reason you don't
see a lot of stacks in middle eastern or
desert countries is what you pointed out
at the beginning palm the heating costs
are brutal yeah i mean our cooling costs
are insanely you know brutal so that's
not it's not time yet because it hasn't
been proven but each year the technology
advances if there is a cooling system
that makes sense they're going to
discover it because most sovereigns want
to mine bitcoin on their own land
where they have control of it where they
can do it ethically and according to the
regulator's rules most people would want
to do that now west texas and the
governor in texas as you well know has
embraced
crypto specifically bitcoin and there is
a ton of capital going to west texas
right now right down to the town level
and so there's multiple projects there
and i think you're going to see a lot of
capital and there's a big initiative on
right now to find an american
manufacturer for stacks so we don't have
to buy anything in china for obvious
reasons china's got itself a little hot
water here and there as you know but we
don't have that yet so there's a lot to
have happen i think this will be
discussed all through 2000 to 2022. this
is where the this is where the puck is
going so i've never told you this story
before but i went to kuwait i think it
was in 2018 maybe and uh while i was
there i was at an event uh very well put
together and uh there was a both
foreigners that were visiting for the
event and also uh kuwaitis and uh one of
them said to me uh hey do you want to
see a kuwait bitcoin mine and i was like
you got a bitcoin mine and he was like
yeah and so we went to dinner and then
afterwards we went to this bitcoin mine
and it literally was in a warehouse
basement so like we went to this
warehouse it was kind of you know you're
like alright where are we and then they
brought me down to the basement and they
showed it to me and it wasn't a huge
operation but it was it was big enough
and uh i remember asking him why are you
in the basement he said well you know
one we might not want everyone to know
that we're doing this here but also too
is there's much more uh kind of cooling
uh capabilities down here so not quite
underground in the desert you know type
thing and not quite the skill you're
talking about uh but you know years ago
there were people who kind of as an
individual or a small business were
trying to figure this out so it's cool
to kind of see that it's evolved to the
point where now you're talking about
large billion dollar facilities still
trying to conceptualize this and put it
into effect